we will hear more from president biden
later today about the steps the u.s is
taking to protect americans against this
latest covet strain now he spent
thanksgiving in nantucket he's now back
at the white house nancy cordes is there
nancy good morning to you
good morning gail the president is
expected to address the nation in just a
few hours about the omicron variant that
comes after he was briefed by his covid
team
at the white house last night his chief
medical advisor dr anthony fauci telling
the president while it's going to take a
couple more weeks to learn enough about
this variant fauci continues to believe
that existing vaccines are likely to
provide a degree of protection against
severe cases of covid now omicron could
present yet another challenge for this
president who just this summer remember
was declaring the country's independence
from kovitt and it all comes during a
crucial few weeks for his agenda as he
tries to pass his build back better plan
in the senate he's hoping by the end of
the month and get other bills passed to
fund the government pass this friday's
deadline and avoid defaulting on the
country's debts by mid-month that's
something that's going to be very
difficult to do with some republicans
signaling they are not going to vote to
raise the debt ceiling cdc officials
were told spent the weekend on the phone
with state and local health officials
keeping them up to speed on what they do
and don't know about this variant yale
all right nancy we're still all
searching for answers thanks a lot